California kills its high-speed rail the
2020 Democrats face some campaign
troubles and ill head Omar escapes
culpability once again I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show all righty
so laden news to get to today we are
going to get into in detail a bunch of
Democratic proposals that even they do
not take seriously it's the reason why
president Trump's approval rating has
risen seven points over the last month
even according to these sort of Real
Clear Politics poll average we'll get to
all of that in just one second first we
need to talk about what you are using to
send your packages this year so I know
Valentine's Day is coming up but it's
not just a Valentine's Day issue it's an
everyday issue what are you going to do
every time you need to schlep your boxes
down to the post office well instead of
doing that what you could do is use
stamps calm postage rates have gone up
again thankfully stamps calm can ease
the pain with big discounts off post
office retail rates with stamps calm you
save five cents off every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
that kind of savings really does add up
especially for small businesses plus
stamps calm is completely online which
saves you time no more inconvenient
trips to the post office
stamps calm automatically calculates and
prints the exact amounts of postage you
need for every letter or package you
send you're never going to overpay or
under pay again stamps.com brings all
the services of the US Postal Service
directly to your fingertips and they
make it really easy they send you a free
digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact postage you need
you can buy and print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail you print it right out
there onto the package or directly onto
a sticker or onto a piece of paper that
you can tape to the box stamps calm
saves you time and money that's why we
use it here at the daily wire right now
our listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and the digital scale see for
yourself why over 700 thousand small
businesses use stamps calm go to stamps
calm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Shapiro
that's Sam's calm enter code Shapiro
stamps calm click on that Mike and her
code Shapiro and get the special deal
alrighty so here is the latest on the
government shutdown it apparently has
been averted president Trump is expected
today to sign into law a bipartisan
Accord to avert another US government
shutdown according to Reuters it's a bad
deal it's a bad deal
this deal basically gives the president
something like one point three seven
five billion dollars for border secure
it allows him to build another 55 miles
offense maybe it's not what he was
looking for it's actually less money
allocated to border security than was
allocated to border security in the
original budget that was proposed by
Democrats back in November the president
Trump turned down now the saving grace
is that President Trump is likely to
declare under 10 USC 284 that drug
corridors must have additional fencing
bill which he can do he can have the
Defense Department mobilized and
redirect funds for that purpose he's
likely to do some of that
he's also illustrated the Democrats are
full-scale crazy on the subject of a
border wall when he did his big event on
Monday night in El Paso
he was talking about the necessity for a
border wall standing about a thousand
feet maybe from the border fencing
between El Paso and Mexico and meanwhile
bata O'Rourke was standing a thousand
feet from him and was saying that walls
are terrible there was a wall at bata
O'Rourke's rally by the way to prevent
people from encroaching onto the
territory of beta or Australia even as
he was proclaiming that walls were
really really bad
on Wednesday CNN the Washington Post and
Wall Street Journal all reported that
Trump intended to sign the measure into
law if it passes Congress
representatives for the White House
could not be reached immediately for
comment Trump on Tuesday did not rule
out vetoing the legislation he said he
was not happy with the deal but he's not
going to get into another shutdown here
again is it a bad deal to President
Trump do a bad job of negotiating this
thing yeah he did I mean he went into a
poker hand and he was bluffing from the
very outset Democrats knew that he was
bluffing
they kept upping the ante and President
Trump was not willing to try to buy the
pot basically he was not willing to
carry the bluff all the way to the final
contingency he was not willing to allow
the government to remain shut down
Democrats knew that and so they were
able to basically win the hand with a
pair of two's
that's essentially what happened in this
particular poker game now again the
President does have another card that
has yet to drop here and that is the
possibility of declaring some sort of
national emergency Zero Hedge is
reporting that the president is
considering exactly that
according to Zero Hedge which is sort of
a little bit of a sketchy website when
it comes to reporting they say in an
interesting twist it looks like Trump
has decided on a middle path that will
allow him to keep the government open
while getting more of his border wall
built than Congress had initially
authorized according to Washington Post
Trump will use an executive order to
reallocate federal funds to finance the
wall or at least something more than the
fifty-five miles that the compromise
bill would finance a White House
official told the post this morning that
the President sees signing the border
deal if passed by Congress is the way to
avoid another shutdown thus according to
Robert Costa but he would also likely
pursue an executive order to reallocate
federal funds to barrier projects the
official said so that is the solution
that probably makes the most political
sense once again president from his big
success here is illustrating once and
for all the Democrats do not care about
border security or at least they don't
care enough about border security
remember it was a point of negotiation
during this actual border negotiation
Democrats wanted to lower the amounts of
funding available just for beds to house
criminal illegal aliens and President
Trump did not want to lower those
numbers because he was saying well we
can't house these people we have to
release them into general society and
Democrats were stumping for that they
were something for Trump's who just
released criminal illegal aliens into
American society it's a pretty good
talking point for President Trump
come 2020 again all President Trump has
to do in 2020 is just point at the
Democrats because they are exposing
their radicalism every single day how
radical are the Democrats even they even
they are scared by their own radicalism
senator Mitch McConnell cocaine Mitch he
really demonstrated that full scale
yesterday so the Democrats have been
going crazy over the green New Deal
everybody loves the green New Deal the
media they love the green new deal
it's ambitious and audacious and hopeful
and bold the green New Deal it's so
wonderful so wonderful that even the
people who sponsored it will not vote
for it that's what Mitchell McConnell
showed yesterday so turtley Mitch he
popped his head out of the shell snorted
some coke and then he said you know
we're gonna do you love this green dune
deal so much yeah I love it too because
it shows who you who you folks are so
how about we do this how about you come
out and we force you Democrats to vote
for it after all you keep talking about
how great and ambitious it is but you
don't want to vote for it remember in
the house which is controlled by
Democrats the green New Deal resolution
did not come up for a vote Republicans
don't control the house that means that
Nancy dentures Pelosi said she was not
going to bring it up for a vote despite
mouthing all sorts of platitudes about
how wonderful and excellent and hopeful
and ambitious the thing was by the way
when politicians say that something is a
bold new idea it's bold in the same way
that my son trying to
plug a toaster into the wall is bull
it's a bold move cotton let's see how
they do with it here's Mitch McConnell
putting Democrats to test hey listen you
guys proposing this thing how about we
just vote on it you know let's see if
you like it that much
Mitch McConnell though I've noted with
great interest the green New Deal and
we're going to be voting on that in the
Senate I'll give everybody an
opportunity to go on record and see how
they feel about the green New Deal
man he is so he is so low-key he's like
Ben Stein of the US Senate and he cannot
hide his glee at this I mean you have to
yeah you have to actually see his face
and this is why if you don't subscribe
to the program over at Daly where you
really should because if you can't see
Mitch McConnell's face for clips like
this what is what his video made for I
mean it's just fantastic so Mitch
McConnell who smiles once every 70 years
he's like Halley's Comet he cannot hold
back a smile at the fact that Democrats
were this stupid so how stupid were the
Democrats with this it's so great it's
just so great so Senator Edward Markey
of Massachusetts you'll recall is the
Senate co-sponsor of this green New Deal
resolution it was sponsored in the House
by the venerable and intelligent and
brilliant young fresh face
AOC so fresh so face Ed Markey who is
not a fresh face is in the Senate in
Massachusetts and he co-sponsored it on
the Senate side and this bill was
endorsed by all the Democratic
heavyweights spartacus Cory Booker
Kamala nark Harris it was co-sponsored
by Elizabeth folk ohonta sworen I mean
like all of the Democrats running
Kirsten I take every side of every issue
Gillibrand all of them endorsed the
green New Deal so Ed Markey is very
concerned though so why now let's say
that you wanted to pass a piece of
legislation you let's say that you
thought that climate change was the most
important issue on America's dial that
Americans needed to be made aware that
this this green New Deal thing had to be
passed as a resolution to demonstrate to
Americans that we need to take this
crisis seriously wouldn't you want it's
coming up for vote
I mean if you wrote the resolution
senator Ed Markey tweeted this out today
it's so fantastic he tweeted out
don't let Mitch McConnell fool you this
is nothing but an attempt to sabotage
the movement we are building he wants to
silence your voice
so Republicans don't have to explain why
they are climate change deniers
McConnell wants this to be the end this
is just the beginning so let's try to
unpack this logic you proposed a bill it
is supported by every major Democratic
heavyweight Mitch McConnell says let's
vote on it and that's sabotage so if
Mitch McConnell didn't bring it up for a
vote then you would say he obviously
doesn't care enough about climate change
he's sabotaging us and if he does bring
it up for a vote then he's sabotaging
your movement if your proposal is so
toxic that the mere fact of bringing it
up for a vote would expose it as toxic
I'm pretty sure you're the one who just
sabotage your own boat yeah Ed Markey is
in the back of the ship drilling a hole
directly through the hall and Mitch
McConnell's like sir if you would if you
would prefer I will bring you a stick of
dynamite and then Mark is like whoa
Mitch McConnell's trying to sabotage
this thing it's your bill dude you wrote
the thing you don't get to claim it
sabotage when Mitch McConnell brings it
up for a vote that's Mitch McConnell
being ultimate trol master Mitch
McConnell cocaine Mitch power move by
cocaine Mitch I do I do love it again it
is hilarious to me the Democrats are now
claiming it is sabotage for Mitch
McConnell to bring up for a vote
a proposal they say is so popular and so
powerful that every American needs to be
made aware of it Mitch McConnell's like
fine let's make every American aware of
it and the co-sponsor of the bill and
the Senate is like no no no no we can't
vote on that I didn't mean it I didn't
really mean it it's it's it really is
amazing I mean it's a situation where
you got in a fight with your spouse and
you just kept upping the ante and then
finally your spouse is like fine go for
it no like oh that's pretty much what
happened here the Democrats kept upping
the ante on how important climate
changes to the point where like let's be
on cars let's kill the farting cows
let's get rid of airplanes let's do all
those things and Mitch McConnell's like
all right that's what you want let's do
this thing let's make it public and some
consoling old bro ownership of the libs
with facts and logic by Mitch McConnell
you got to love that it's an underrated
politician is Mitch McConnell and for
all the crap we give him for his
negotiations on border measures Power
Move Power Move now one of the things
that's hilarious about the new wave of
Democrats is that all of their proposals
are similarly
ambitious and similarly stupid and
similarly undoable and we are finding
this out day after day when they run
screaming from their own proposals like
legitimately they run screaming from
their own proposals I'll give you a
couple of examples in just one second
from across the country Democrats
propose audacious ambitious bold things
like my son with the toaster they
propose bold things and then they find
their the dog that catches the car and
then they realize that by catching the
car they've now put themselves in direct
proximity to the back wheels and if that
thing is in Reverse they're gonna get
smooshed we'll talk about it in just one
second first let's talk about the best
present I really think that you can get
a parent a sibling yourself I'm talking
about legacy box your life is a series
of experiences and memories but right
now you've got all those experiences and
memories sitting out in the garage
moldering a bunch of old pictures that
are being are being bug-infested
well instead of all that old tape that
you can no longer play because it's on
actual film reels well you should do is
send all that stuff over to legacy box
and then they take all that stuff they
put it in digital format and they send
it back to you it's really awesome
you can save your family films and
photos from degrading or being lost
forever
you can put them in a usable format you
can make sure that if god forbid
something were to happen to your garage
then you've got all of those memories
saved you can ensure your family history
is preserved forever send your legacy
box filled with old home movies and
pictures they do the rest they
professionally digitize your moments
onto a thumb drive digital download or
DVD
they have easy-to-follow instructions
and safety bar codes included for every
item so you can track every item as it
goes along in the process you get all
your original recorded moments back
along with perfectly preserved digital
copies and you get personalized updates
every step of the way receiving up to 12
personalized email updates every time
that there's that there's an issue
there's never been a better time to
digitally preserve your memories visit
legacy voxcom
today to get started I really think it's
a deeply important thing it's not just a
great gift it's an important thing
because your life is your memories plus
for a limited time they are offering my
listeners an exclusive discount so go to
legacy box comm slash button and get 40%
off your first order that's legacy box
comm slash men get 40% off today start
preserving your past make it available
for your kids I mean it's really
important stuff legacy box comm slash
been use that slash been get 40% off
your first order okay so how unrealistic
how unrealistic our democratic plans
Democratic plans are so unrealistic that
first
here's usually how this math works
usually some Democrat proposes something
insane and stupid then the saner
Democrats in the room go oh that's a bad
idea but then the crazy Democrats gain
the momentum and then the same Democrats
start to embrace the crazy they start to
embrace the crazy and then they realize
after trying this thing for a couple of
years it's totally crazy in the abandon
it this is how a lot of Democratic plans
end so for example in the state of
California we have a governor his name
is Gavin Newsom he's basically a living
Ken doll with all the brains that come
along with it and Gavin Newsom was
lieutenant governor
well back in 2014 I had Gavin Newsom on
my radio show and I specifically asked
him about a proposal that Californians
had voted in favor of for high-speed
rail between San Francisco and Los
Angeles would have stops in places like
Sacramento
it would have stops in Bakersfield for
whatever reason and this was going to
cost us legitimately billions and
billions of dollars like billions of
dollars this high-speed rail now those
of us who live in California we're
sitting around going but isn't there a
giant highway called the i-5 that also
connects Los Angeles with San Francisco
and the answer was yes there is a giant
highway called the i-5 that connects all
of these various cities but it was very
important that we build up high-speed
bullet train in one of the most sparsely
populated areas of California that giant
corridor where no one lives except for
Bakersfield and Fresno between
Sacramento and Los Angeles deeply deeply
important to spend billions of dollars
on that monstrosity
well I asked Gavin Newsom about this all
the way back in 2014 so now five years
ago I asked him about this and he said
at the time yeah this is a really dumb
idea we shouldn't do it are you pro or
against the Train especially given the
fact that the Californian public which
approved the Train in the first place
now has reneged and no longer likes the
Train yeah I think I'm where the public
was and is it I would take the dollars
and redirect it to other more pressing
infrastructure needs and I am not the
only Democrat that feels this way and I
got to tell you I am one of the few that
just said it publicly most of not saying
it privately right he said it publicly
and then he immediately backtracked
because the frame was already off and
running
we were already gonna do the trade man
Jerry Brown was Jerry Brown our governor
who is 1000 years old he's actually I
think he passed away sadly about ten
years ago and they've just been wheeling
him around ever since and then playing a
tape of Jerry Brown from
his head and so every so often he sort
of nods off in the middle of press
conferences it's a great trend well
Jerry Brown made the Train super popular
among Democrats but and then Gavin
Newsom embraced it he was like yeah the
Train is great I love the Train now and
he completely flipped on it it's a big
story
back when he was running for governor
that he flipped on the Train well now
Gavin Newsom has flipped back on the
train because it now turns out that this
is was a stupid idea in the first place
so in a second I'm gonna get to that
gavin newsom the new governor of
california said this during his first
State of the State speech he surprised
listeners by announcing he would put the
quest for high-speed rail connecting San
Francisco and LA championed by his
predecessor far on the back burner
instead Newsom offered a consolation
prize high-speed rail between
Bakersfield and Merced oh yeah
glamour get on that high-speed rail you
know with your cocktail the Love Train
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna drive
my wife over to Bakersfield and I'm
gonna say you know what honey let's take
a romantic trip to Merced as we're gonna
do were to spend billions of dollars for
a high-speed rail between two cities
that unless you live there these are not
tourist destinations nobody and nobody
in New York is like you know what summer
vacation what do you say we go to Merced
yeah these are not places where people
they're not even destinations in
California take Bakersfield is a city
it's fine I've been there Merced also a
city great do we need a high-speed rail
connecting these two cities of course we
don't but he's using this as now a
consolation prize because we're not
actually going to build a high-speed
rail between San Francisco and LA which
by the way was always an idiotic idea we
were talking about spending literally
billions of public dollars building a
high-speed rail between San Francisco
and Los Angeles you know how much it
cost you for a plane ticket between LA
and San Francisco one way it's like 80
bucks
it's legitimately like Southwest puts on
deals for under $100 you could make that
you could make that travel happen and it
would take you less time going to the
airport than it would to get on that
bullet train and yet we were gonna spend
billions of dollars now even Democrats
have to back off of this nuisance said
let's level about the high-speed rail
let's be real the current project his
plan would cost too much and
respectfully take too long right now
there simply isn't a path to get from
San Francisco to San Diego
let alone from San Francisco to LA I
wish there were fortunately there is it
is called the i-5 I Drive it all the
time so does everyone else in the state
of California not only that we have
these things I know controversial will
they are they were invented in the early
20th century and if you it's a vehicle
and if you drive it fast enough and you
have enough thrust behind the vehicle
and the wings are actually directed at
the proper angle to the ground these
things fly I know it's wild these giant
machines they fly and they will take you
from LA to San Francisco through the air
I mean that's high-tech right there
maybe we should invest in those recent
estimates assess Governor Jerry Brown's
plan would cost seventy seven billions
ow seventy seven billion dollars I kid
you not so I'm just gonna do a quick
back of the envelope calculation right
now
okay seventy seven billion dollars
divided by the price of a one-way ticket
like 80 bucks to Sacramento or San
Francisco that would pay for those at
the state of California could
legitimately for that same price pay for
962 million five hundred thousand
tickets really they could pay 962
million nine six to five hundred
thousand tickets okay which there there
are about 50 million residents in the
state of California so let's divide that
so that means that we could pay for
nineteen point two five one-way tickets
for every person living in the state of
California
every single person living in the state
of California right this very instant we
could pay for twenty tickets between LA
and San Francisco via plane for the
price that it would take to build this
stupid high-speed honestly Jerry Brown
the Democrats in California they're just
the guy from The Simpsons they're just
the monorail guy from The Simpsons it's
truly amazing so you know well done it
was always an idiotic plan everybody
already knew it was an idiotic plan and
yet we were supposed to pretend it was
not an idiotic plan by the way it's
actually more tickets than that because
they're not forty million they're not
fifty million residents in the state of
California there are 40 million
residents in the state of California so
we could pay for 24 tickets for every
residents in the state of California to
go from LA to San Francisco
and and yet we were gonna spend all this
money the point here is the Democrats
say dumb things like it's a moonshot you
know is the cool thing about the
moonshot we got to the moon you notice
the bad news about a high-speed rail
between Merced and Bakersfield you end
up in either Merced or Bakersfield and
they're fine together they're fine it's
not exactly the moon also you know how
much it would cost me to drive from
recite to Bakersfield like a tank of gas
like 20 bucks maybe 30 bucks maybe oh my
goodness so this is one of the things
you got to love about Democrats they
make these proposals and then they have
to back off their own proposals it's
just like the state of California at one
point had considered universal health
care and then they were like oh yeah we
can't pay for that it was like well you
are the most left-leaning state in
America you the most left-leaning state
in America and your own Democratic
Senate would not even vote on it why
because universal health care in
California would cost 17 billion dollars
per year 17 billion dollars per year and
the budget of the state of California
last I checked is 200 billion dollars
two hundred billion dollars so it cost
an additional twenty billion dollars per
year minimum okay that that is not a
thing that is going to happen and you're
seeing it play out in New York to where
New York has pursued every idiotic
policy they can possibly think of and
now they're shocked shocked that none of
their policies are working out so
Governor Andrew Cuomo who is as we have
said in a running gun battle with his
brother to be the stupider Cuomo brother
we have a block of wood on CNN and then
we have the governor of New York who is
a block of slightly more brittle wood a
little bit older so a petrified stone
well he is now complaining about Florida
why is New York complaining about
Florida because it turns out anyone with
money is trying to get out of New York
and into Florida so here is is what CBS
Miami reports he said this week the
governor of New York blamed budget
shortfalls on the state of Florida
so he's blaming his own inability to
take in tax dollars in New York on
Florida why he said New Yorkers were
fleeing to the Sunshine State to save
big time on taxes it all goes back to
the tax reform passed by Congress the
changes increased the incentive to move
to the Sunshine State dramatically
well why because one of the things that
the tax bill did is it did not exempt
state taxes
from federal income tax so people who
are high income in states like
California and New York where you're
already paying an inordinate state tax
they couldn't take that as a discount on
their federal taxes so you're basically
getting double taxed in states like
California and New York the point being
that there shouldn't be a federal
incentive for states to raise their
taxes so what he's really complaining
about is that Florida isn't governed
like complete garbage and New York is
governed like complete garbage and when
you raise taxes inordinate lis you end
up driving people out of the state
you'll recall that just a week ago
Andrew Cuomo basically admitted they
can't tax people in New York anymore
because if they keep taxing people all
the billionaires leave all the
millionaire's leave no one wants to be
in these badly governed states bad
democratic ideas will not even be
embraced by bad Democrats at this point
and yet we're supposed to let them
govern based on their high hopes and
their commitment their commitment to the
future they're ambitious and bold the
plans
yeah let's handle governance to these to
these Schmucks you know get to a little
bit more of this in just a second let's
talk about the presidential race so a
lot of these Democrats are having a very
very difficult time in the presidential
race because they they have what Sarah
Jessica Parker might call failure to
launch one of those candidates is
senator Amy Klobuchar of Minnesota who
has been described as Minnesota nice
which I guess is just a euphemism for I
throw binders at my staffers that was a
report that came out in the last couple
of weeks is that she is apparently
allegedly routinely abusive to her
staffers up to and including throwing
objects at her staffers I have to say
there are a lot of people who work at
this company and when I abused them I do
it publicly on-air
all right well behind the scenes I'm
actually much nicer than I am to to
folks on air they won't confirm this and
if they don't I'll fire them I mean this
is this is the reality of how things
work here I it has never even crossed my
mind to throw objects at the people who
work here number one it's a lawsuit and
number two you shouldn't throw objects
at people hey I don't even let my kids
throw objects at each other I mean
khalaby try reportedly took binders and
threw them at people so MIT Romney not
fit to be President because he had a
binder full of women he thought about
hiring Amy claw HR a woman who throws
binders now being considered for
president now the best part of this is a
great story
- according to media in a potentially
embarrassing AP report for senator Amy
Klobuchar more than a dozen current and
former staffers described her as an
abusive boss who often tried to have job
offers rescinded when they tried to jump
ship interviews with some of cloud
charts Capitol Hill staffers portray a
hostile work environment run on fear
abuse and humiliation
according to staffers the overly
critical senator will sometimes turn a
single mistake into a multi-day affair
of shaming and demeaning followed by
post work angry late-night phone calls
and all-caps emails the way she treats
staff is disqualifying sent a former
female staffer and one of the staffers
says I will not vote for her because
she's a bad person three former club HR
staffers told The Huffington Post their
boss made them or their co-workers run
personal errands for her such as picking
up her dry cleaning packing her
suitcases for travel and even cleaning
and washing her dishes at home and
frankly I want to be a senator that
sounds great
if I can make my staffers do this sort
of stuff are you kidding me like on the
public dime they make people wash my
dishes on the public dime that sounds
amazing
she has one of the highest rates of
staff turnover in Congress so how widely
has claw Bashar's
mistreatment of her staff been rumored
it's been rumored so widely that Sno
actually a veep writer confirmed a
writer for the show veep confirmed that
they had a joke on the show about a
staffer shaving Amy clapper char's legs
and that joke was inspired by reality
that they had heard a rumor that the
staffers were so abused that they were
like shaving the Senators legs and so
they made a similar joke on veep that's
how bad the rumors have been about Amy
klava charge so Minnesota nice when they
say Minnesota nice they don't actually
mean the the Frances McDormand character
in Fargo they mean the guy who throws
people into a wood chipper on Fargo so
Amy Klobuchar are having a tough time
meanwhile qumola hair is having a tough
time because she's a narc so one of the
most beautiful things is watching as far
left Democratic candidates are not far
left enough for the Democratic base
combo Harris was a prosecutor this is a
nearly disqualifying for a lot of people
on the far left in the Democratic Party
they look at common law Harris and they
say well this lady prosecuted people and
put them in jail this means that she is
a narc and so we can't let her anywhere
near the halls of power
we need the people who say they want to
disband ice who said they want to defund
the Department of Homeland Security
meanwhile Trump is back there just
twiddling his thumbs going this is great
keep going please my good I won't say
what other contexts Trump may have said
such things in in any case Kamala Harris
this is a bad story for her now this
would be a good story for somebody in
any normal time in any normal time this
story about Kamala Harris would be a
non-story it would be actually a point
in her favor for moderates but in the
modern Democratic Party it is a point
against her according to CNN Kamala
Harris supported a 2008 San Francisco
policy that reported arrested
undocumented juveniles to ice oh no
she's a she law and order Kamala Harris
supported if a 17 year old illegal
immigrant killed someone reporting them
to ice I'm sorry she's she's too
moderate for the modern-day Democratic
Party according to CNN as District
Attorney of San Francisco Kamala Harris
supported a city policy that required
law enforcement to turn over
undocumented juvenile immigrants to
federal immigration authorities if they
were arrested and suspected of
committing a felony regardless of
whether they were actually convicted of
a crime harris cited with then mayor
Gavin Newsom in a political fight over
San Francisco status as a sanctuary city
that split the city's municipal
government with the mayor's office
supporting the policy and the city's
elected Board of Supervisors opposing it
a common law Harris is too much of a
narc for the Democratic base her past
position according to CNN could open her
up to attacks from immigration activists
as well as the more progressive wing of
the party as she seeks the Democratic
nomination in 2020 the fight over the
San Francisco policy was covered
extensively at the time but Harris's
role has not been closely examined since
she entered the national spotlight in a
statement to CNN Harris's campaign
spokesman Ian Samms said the policy was
intended to protect the sanctuary status
of San Francisco and to ensure local
police who needed to have strong
relationships with the communities they
serve regardless of immigration status
were not forced to operate as
immigration agents which is the
responsibility of the federal government
looking back this policy could have been
applied more fairly uh-oh that last line
is a killer for Kamala Harris because
that means she is going to be accused of
anti-immigrant racism so Democrats be
hoist hoist it on their own petard here
and there now in a serious problem
because it turns out that the Democratic
base is too crazy for the candidates
like legitimately too crazy for the
camera candidates how crazy is our
segments of the Democratic base segments
of the Democratic base are angry at
common law Harris because she's married
to a white person really she was she was
asked specifically in an interview why
she was married to a white man and she
answered it she Ashley answered the
question because this was considered a
legitimate question she was asked in an
interview on Monday why she married a
white man and how she could do so while
defending her black heritage and she
said look I love my husband he happened
to be the one that I chose to marry
because I loved him and that was that
moment in time and that's it and he
loves me but I love the fact that this
is I love the fact that this is
controversial here is common law Harris
giving an answer like legitimately
answering a question that should never
have been asked online all the time and
I I don't think it's fair I don't even
think the person who life should matter
but they do mention your husband uh huh
and his house
she's so black was she married wait look
I love my husband and he happened to be
the one that I chose to marry because I
love him and that was that moment in
time and I'm that's it
that's it he loves me the proper answer
there the proper answer is what the hell
kind of question is that
I mean imagine that was a white
candidate who had married a black woman
or the opposite of white woman who
married a black man and let's say that
that person had been asked you know
there are a lot of people asking about
you Marian cross racially wouldn't the
answer be what a racist question we live
in a free country where I can marry
whomever I damn well please and color
shouldn't matter wouldn't that be the
proper answer the fact that Kamala
Harris has to take that question
seriously is a demonstration that our
politics is full-scale broken then
intersectional politics is evil that
question itself is an evil question why
did you marry a white guy
how disgusting truly okay and a second
we're gonna get to other problems that
the Democrats are having with their own
base but first you're going to have to
go over to Daley wire and subscribe when
you subscribe you get not only the rest
of this show live you also get two
additional hours of this show every day
I mean my goodness and it's full full to
the brim with great stuff not only as we
have updates from news over the course
of the day we also have fantastic guests
I mean we've been averaging basically a
senator a day on this
we have all sorts of wonderful material
that you won't get if you just listen to
the podcast itself and when you
subscribe you get access to that
commercial free behind the paywall which
is pretty great on demand if thousands
of people who watch it live as
subscribers and during the breaks I
sometimes take questions as well so you
can interact with me which is a cool
thing so go check that out also when you
subscribe you also get the extra
question in our Sunday special for $99 a
year by the way you get all of this nine
nine nine ninety-nine a month or $99 a
year for the $99 here you also get this
you left his tears hot or cold tumblr
notice it says leftist not liberal I get
a lot of questions about this tumblr
aren't you being discriminatory no left
to start are terrible and leftism is
terrible liberalism urges people with
whom I disagree leftism leftists are
people who want to shut down the debate
and/or nationalize all industry in any
case go check all of that out also as I
say subscribe to YouTube and iTunes so
that you can get the Sunday special
which by the way available a day early
on Saturdays for our daily wire
subscribers this week's Sunday special
Daniel Krauthammer the son of the late
Charles Krauthammer here's a little bit
of that this Sunday I'm the Ben Shapiro
Sunday special we're hosting Daniel
Krauthammer the son of Charles
Krauthammer
I am very glad to be on with Ben I will
be talking about my father Charles
Krauthammer his last book the point of
it all his life his writings and his
legacy okay so it is totally a
worthwhile listen we talked a lot about
Krauthammer who I think was one of the
seminal figures of 20th and 21st century
conservatism so go check that out and
leave us a review over at iTunes and
YouTube that always helps us we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
as we say the Democrats the Democrat
candidates for 2020 are being outflanked
by their own base and so virtually every
Democratic candidate is now being
dragged through the mud for saying some
quasi moderate things so for example
cory booker the other day who you know
Spartacus very very brave person
Spartacus he said something not terrible
unraised and he is just being ripped up
and down over it he was in Des Moines
and he was specifically asked about the
Virginia situation with people who had
dressed up as as Michael Jackson or
rappers back in 1980 and heroes Booker's
answer which by the way for the record
is actually a pretty good answer having
the conversation about people falling
into a defensive Crouch because
sometimes we both want to tell the truth
about something they fear speaking the
truth or telling the people that what
they don't understand we gotta tell the
truth but we all of us black white gay
straight we've got a so extending grace
to each other so we can have honest
conversations and people are angry at
him for saying this for him saying we
need to have grace with each other and
maybe acknowledge that some people have
been ignorant in the past about their
activities and maybe we expense 10
forgiveness people are angry at him
about this the Democratic base is too
radical even for the most radical
members of the Democratic Party but
that's only part of the Democratic base
and this is why you have a split this is
why you end up with a situation where
every Democratic candidate is endorsing
the green New Deal that Democrats are
scared to death will be brought to the
floor of the Senate for a vote that is
why and it's also why you're seeing some
of the most pandering ridiculous moves
by Democratic candidates so Elizabeth
Warren the non-native American senator
from Massachusetts she actually showed
up on Tuesday to do her professional
pandering on according to CNN she showed
up on Tuesday she made unapparent
unannounced appearance at a lunch on the
sidelines of a major Native American
conference in Washington which again bad
form you know white people take me over
Native American territory that is not a
good thing Elizabeth Warren her remarks
came amid continued scrutiny of the
Massachusetts senators past claims to
native ancestry according to details
provided by a campaign aide after
Warren's appearance at the National
Indian women's lunch honor luncheon she
introduced Wampanoag tribe of gay head a
queen a chairwoman Sheryl Sheryl
mattias a tribal leader and former
senior advisor to the assistant
secretary of Indian Affairs during the
Obama administration the senator was
introduced by New Mexico representative
Deb Hollen who's one of the first two
Native American women elected to
Congress last year Warren did not
address or make any mention of the
controversy surrounding her past claims
to Native American heritage an aide told
CNN including an attempt to prove her
ancestry with the DNA test last year
apparently in her introduction she said
whether it's building coalitions among
allies or reaching across the aisle to
bridge divides Sheryl is masterful at
persuading public policymakers to do
what's right for Native communities so
Elizabeth Warren because she has to keep
pandering to the intersectional crowd
she cannot stop herself from putting her
hand directly on the stove she is just
going to keep going back to that abscess
tooth and sticking her tongue in it over
and over and over nothing she does is
going to change the fact that she lied
about her Native American status for
years nothing is gonna change that fact
and yet she keeps going back to it I
mean she's very bad at this game and
she's not gonna be forgiven to it
because forget forgiveness is not an
aspect of the Democratic Left there is
no forgiveness for the Democratic Left
there's convenience Ralph Northam will
be left as governor of Virginia out of
convenience just in Fairfax may survive
as lieutenant governor of Virginia out
of mere convenience but there is no
forgiveness if you actually cross a line
for Democrats Elizabeth Warren crossed
the line that means no forgiveness is
available the Democratic base is radical
and they are vicious and Howard Schultz
is finding that out too the former
Starbucks CEO he's doing his national
campaign and he got himself in all sorts
of trouble yesterday because again he
said some stuff that the Democratic base
does not want to hear one of the things
he said is that he does not actually see
color right and you're not allowed to
say this you're not allowed to say that
you don't see color in the modern United
States to the Democratic base you're
supposed to say I see color because I'm
a white person and white people see
color and white people are racist that's
what you're supposed to say here's
Howard Schultz saying the opposite this
is going to alienate the Democratic base
it was a terrible moment for the company
it's not something that we're gonna
forget and it's something that we
learned a great deal from and we're
still learning it about and I would just
say as somebody who grew up in a very
diverse background as a young boy in the
projects I didn't see color as a young
boy and I honestly don't see color now
oh you're not allowed to say that
everybody sees color Howard Schultz how
terrible for Howard Schultz to say this
he's got an enormous blow back from the
left for saying that he is colorblind
and tries not to see color he's getting
ripped up and down for it by the way the
fact that he even acknowledges that
something bad happened in Philadelphia
is in and of itself a joke I've talked
to people who went down to that
Philadelphia Starbucks not only are
there cameras in the Philadelphia
Starbucks that could have shed light on
the situation
and then Starbucks did not release the
tape because they had already jumped on
the PC bandwagon but the woman if you
recall the Starbucks situation from
several months ago what happened is that
two black men went into a Starbucks they
were asked repeatedly to buy something
if they wanted to use the restroom they
apparently sat there for hours and then
when the police were called they refused
to leave the restaurant they just stood
there and basically asked to be arrested
as though this were a civil rights
sit-in at a Starbucks in Philadelphia a
city which is plurality black as though
no one's ever seen a black person in
Philadelphia before it turns out that
the woman behind the counter who was
slandered as a racist is according to
people who know her a far-left
LGBTQ activist and choose slandered as a
racist for all of this so Howard Schultz
not only is not wrong about any of this
stuff Howard Schultz is actually bending
over backwards to pretend that this was
a situation of the Philadelphia
Starbucks but the fact that Howard
Schultz says reasonable things from time
to time makes him completely unpalatable
to Democrats and puts him directly in
there in their crosshairs are you
surprised by the blowback some of it
hostile was that take you by surprise
and we were not surprised by it I think
the extent of it has taken us back a bit
but I think any time you try and go
against the grain and take the road less
traveled and challenge the status quo
and actually that's something I've been
doing my whole life but not not at this
level clearly we're gonna have some
resistance so we expected it perhaps not
as acute as it is edges become well I
mean frankly I'm shocked that Howard
Schultz finds himself taken aback at the
radicalism of his own political side of
the aisle
they've been radical for a long time now
I said earlier the Democrats have no
forgiveness for people who have violated
their standards but this is exactly the
point you can always tell what violates
democratic standards by the standard of
forgiveness they use so Democrats have
no standard of forgiveness when it comes
to things that they perceive as
even if they are not in fact anti-black
they have no they have no forgiveness
for stuff that is perceived as anti-gay
like you know Christian churches no
forgiveness there no grace there but you
can always tell what their standards are
by where they are willing to apply
forgiveness and this brings us to Ilhan
Omar
so Ilhan Omar for the 1000th time over
the weekend said something anti-semitic
she has a long history of being an
anti-semite okay this is not her making
a mistake she has a history of
anti-semitism not only that her
anti-semitism continues she's slated
still to speak February 23rd next to an
actual advocate of anti-jewish terror al
head Omar has a long history of this
sort of stuff and yet Democrats are
willing to forgive her pretty much
anything they're willing to forgive her
why because this did not violate their
standards end of story
the New Democratic Party is okay with
generalized anti-semitism so long as you
can couch it in anti Zionist anti-israel
terms so long as you can hide your
anti-semitism behind outdated silly
notions about Israel as a fascist state
so long as you can do that you can get
away with it Ilhan Omar's only boo-boo
is that she came out front and said
something openly anti-semitic but if you
can even mildly pretend you're not
anti-semitic while being completely
anti-semitic then you get away with it
case in point is aoc who just a week ago
tweeted out that she had a conversation
with Jeremy Corbyn who is an open
vicious Pro terrorist anti-semite the
head of the Labour Party in Britain and
AOC tweeted that out and people are like
oh you know he's an anti-semite she's
like oh I'll check into it no follow-up
none the media have not asked her a
single question since about any of that
AOC came out yesterday and actually
defended Ilhan Omar so ill head Omar
you'll recall over the weekend suggested
that Jew money was behind the American
support for Israel which of course is
not true and then Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez came out and defended her well
first Alexandra Ocasio Cortez came out
and tweeted something from Peter Bernard
who is a self-hating Jew of the highest
order a Hamas defender of the highest
order he wrote a piece for the very
left-leaning often anti-semitic for word
magazine a Jewish magazine that really
is willing to defend any level of
anti-semitism including in many cases
open anti-semitism Peter Bernard had
said if you denounce Ilhan Omar but
support Donald Trump
you don't really oppose bigotry you
don't even really oppose
anti-semitism what you opposes criticism
of Israel except that Trump is not
anti-semitic there's no evidence of his
anti-semitism and ohana Maher is an open
anti-semite who has called for the
full-scale destruction of the State of
Israel basically hey which is it in and
of itself and somatic aoc then tweeted
out the Peter Brian art piece and she
tweeted unlike this president because
this is the fallback position for every
Democrat is don't pay attention to how
evil I am Trump that's always the
fallback position so aoc tweeted out in
support of Ilhan Omar unlike this
president representative Ilhan Omar
demonstrated a capacity to acknowledge
pain and apologize use the opportunity
to learn about history of anti-semitism
and grow from it while clarifying her
stance that is a why she's not learned a
damn thing about anti-semitism she
doesn't care about anti-semitism she's a
longtime anti-semite in fact there was a
story that came out yesterday that for
years the Jewish community in the Twin
Cities has been trying to have normal
conversations with Ilhan Omar and they
have been absolutely shocked by her
attitude about anti-semitism so the this
notion that she is somehow doing
something out of the box and she's not
really an anti-semite that is that is
betrayed by her entire record this is a
piece from Twin Cities calm
Ilhan Omar has been talked to about this
before last year before she was elected
to the House of Representatives before
she emerged from a crowded Democratic
field in Minnesota's liberal fifth
congressional district leaders of
Minneapolis is Jewish community fashion
what could be described as an
anti-semitic intervention of Omar a
rising star of the left whose remarks
had made many fellow Democrats in the
Jewish community uncomfortable this is
relevant because Omar a freshman member
of Congress has come under fire this
week after suggesting on Twitter that
supporters of Israel in Congress are
bought and paid for by a bipartisan
pro-israel lobbying group too many of
the remark went beyond a critique of
money's influence in politics and evoked
the anti-semitic myth that Jews seek to
control the world via money the response
by some raging from Chelsea Clinton to
fellow u.s. representative Dean Phillips
of Minnesota is to engage her in a type
of educational discussion apparently
this has already been tried last year
State Senator ROM Lance a st. Louis Park
Democrat who has served in the
legislature since 2002 invited Omar to
his house where a number of Jewish
leaders had gathered it wasn't an ambush
Omar knew the group was there and their
purpose was to enlighten her maybe Omar
who spent four years from age 8 to 12
in a kenyan camp for Somali refugees
just didn't understand less were called
some wandering at the time the apex or
nadir of anti-semitism the Holocaust
would be a matter of European history
for a then 36 year old Muslim native of
Somalia did she know it the trappings of
anti-semitism in Minneapolis restricted
hospitals country clubs property
covenants were American manifestations
that vanished decades before Omar came
to America the subtleties of language
the code words used to marginalize Jews
did she understand the nuance
latts recalled we wanted to reach out to
her we were a bit troubled about several
things she had said among those things
was a 2012 tweet in which Omar wrote
Israel has hypnotized the world may
Allah awaken the people and help them
see the evil doings of Israel as of
Tuesday morning Omar had still not
deleted the tweet even after supposedly
apologizing for it
apparently lat emphasized the problem
wasn't the policy dispute with addiction
and the tone they had a two hour
gathering with Ilhan Omar he declined to
recall the exact statements made by him
or others but here is his summary over
the course of two hours we shared with
her our concerns for things including
language that has references and
meanings beyond just the meanings of
words tropes dog whistles call them what
you will we explained to her how hurtful
and how factually inaccurate they were
most of us came out of that conversation
very troubled by the answers we received
remember this is four years ago I was
not convinced she was going to give a
balanced approach to policy in the
Middle East and I was not convinced
where her heart is on these things okay
so the bottom line is that Omar has been
a long-time anti-semite she continues to
trafficking anti-semitism and Democrats
don't care they don't they forced a fake
apology out of her they're not removing
her from any committee assignments she's
had to apologize for anti system
anti-semitism two times in the last four
weeks when Steve King said a thing
that was construed as openly racist he
was removed of all committee assignments
by a Republican Congress Johann Omar has
twice in four weeks apologized for open
anti-semitism and we're gonna treat her
like she's a five-year-old as though she
doesn't know what she's saying when
she's been saying openly anti-semitic
garbage for years on end why because as
I say the Democrats brook no forgiveness
for people who violate the standards
they care about but they don't actually
care about anti-semitism their
forgiveness is readily available there
Ilhan Omar maintains her status as a
fresh face of the Democratic Party a OMA
her status as a fresh-faced Rasheeda
Talib another anti-semite retains her
status as a fresh face because the
anti-semitism in the Democratic Party is
not a violation of standards it is in
fact the new standard the new standard
is anti-israel anti-zionism that borders
and crosses over into anti-semitism all
too frequently alrighty
time for some things I like and some
things that I hate so things that I like
Bill Gates has apparently fed up with
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez as well he
should be because her proposals are
silly
they are backwards they're asinine and
they're counterproductive even Bill
Gates was a very left-leaning dude a
career Democrat he says that AOC is
missing the big picture that that she
just doesn't get it what do you make of
the notion that our government should
work harder the idea that we should just
tax folks like you a 70% marginal tax
rate and that that money should be used
to build infrastructure and services
like this certainly the idea the
government be more effective in terms of
how it runs education or social programs
you know there's a lot of opportunity
for improvement there we can be more
progressive the estate tax and the tax
on capital the way the FICA Social
Security tax works we can be more
progressive without really threatening
the the income generation so you're not
looking at here and of like modern
monetary theory that says don't worry
about the deficit we'll just print the
money and do it that is some crazy stalk
it's I mean it's certainly out there
it's gaining currency well that's crazy
it will come and bite you that is the
the people you owe the money to you will
have a problem well Bill Gates who knows
something about money generation and
generating jobs and is a career Democrat
is coming out and saying the new
Democratic Party is out of its mind he
will be cast out with scorn and hatred
within the next five years the
Democratic Party has just moved too far
to the left now if we're going to become
the Soviet Union if AOC were to receive
her wish and we'd nationalize all
industry we would abolish capitalism and
all the rest people would die it would
be a pretty terrible place it would be
pretty awful for the economy of the
world the Soviet Union an awful evil
terrible no good very bad place the one
thing the one upside had a great
national anthem I mean I know awkward
but they did in fact the national anthem
for the Soviet Union was so good
that Vladimir Putin recently brought it
back and changed the words because the
national anthem for the Soviets is
pretty
right here's a little bit the Soviet
national anthem we may as well just get
used to it since presumably this will be
played at the 2024 Democratic National
Convention when AOC is nominated
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a great national anthem
unbelievably evil country fantastic
national so there's that I mean if we're
gonna go down this path maybe we can I
mean a better national anthem than our
national anthem just on a musical level
not in the freedom level obviously but
on a musical level I've been a longtime
believer that we should actually
substitute America the Beautiful for our
national anthem I think our now I think
the star-spangled banner is just musical
garbage it actually was an old British
drinking song and you know that
interesting anyway so that is that also
if you if you enjoy that you can watch
the hunt for an October where people
actually sing the Soviet national anthem
to let the Americans find these Soviet
defectors which is pretty great okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
okay so over the over the last couple of
days President Trump held this rally in
El Paso it was a big story because a
cameraman was attacked at the Trump
rally there's a little bit of tape of
what that actually looked like here was
president from speaking and then you
will see what happened to this camera
person
[Applause]
okay a little bit hard to see but
basically there's a cameraman a guy in a
Maggie had pushed the guy over now what
the media are not reporting is that the
crowd started booing the guy who pushed
over the reporter and who's being held
back by another guy in a maganet so you
know that seems to me a bad person doing
a bad thing and other people there
stopping him the White House
Correspondents Association then tried to
blame it on Trump the White House
Correspondents Association put out a
statement saying that they condemn the
physical attack on our colleague at the
president's rally in El Paso Texas we're
relieved that this time no one was
seriously hurt the President of the
United States should make absolutely
clear to his supporters that violence
against reporters is unacceptable well
honestly like that the administration
has said that multiple times and they
repeated that this morning with sarah
huckabee sanders going on TV and saying
of course we condemn this violence we
don't want violence against reporters we
just think that they should stop fibbing
but those those are completely separable
reporters should actually report the
news and be better at their jobs and
also separately
no one should attack anybody else in a
civilized country you condemn any sort
of attacks on anybody right absolutely
and the idea that the president or
anybody on his team or in his
administration would encourage violence
is absolutely absurd the president
stopped aston made sure everyone was
okay before continuing on with the event
certainly we condemn violence in any
form against anyone and that certainly
includes the press of course that's true
there is this weird relationship the
press has to free speech where they say
that certain speech causes violence but
not if it's left to speech so Bernie
Sanders supporter shoots a bunch of
Congress people on a baseball field
nothing to do with Bernie Sanders which
by the way I generally agree with a
trump supporter assaults a journalist at
a trump rally obviously Trump's fault
you can't have it both ways okay either
words only cause violence when you are
actively encouraging violence or words
cause violence if a cracked person could
take them to heart you're gonna have to
choose and if that's the case then beta
O'Rourke should preemptively condemn
violence because at his rally there were
people who beating the living crap out
of a out of a Donald Trump pinata okay
so the pinata is not a person but I
think it's fair to say this is a
somewhat violent activity obviously
[Music]
[Applause]
so good times over there at the bado
rally and the tenor of politics in our
country does have to change pretty
radically but I think that if the media
are going to try and blame Trump for
violence then they're gonna have to hold
an equal standard I'm a big fan of
objective standards I like a country of
rules not arbitrarily applied standards
I like to know what the rules are before
we get into the political game in the
first place okay we'll be back a little
bit later today with two more hours
which is why you should subscribe at
daily wire.com if not we will see you
back here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19